welcome to this video for Brandon of the
chess olympiad 2012 in Istanbul round 10
also means the penultimate round so
after this is only one round to go on
September the ninth um yeah it's a very
very closer call now for for the title
um today we had done yesterday round 10
we had done the match China against the
United States which China one so the
United States couldn't really young
continue the great showing against
Russia the day before yeah the match was
won by China do to win by ding Liren on
bought three against only shook who lost
a really very draws repent game um quite
surprised really that she lost it
because it's got excellent technical
abilities and I'm not quite sure what
happened them on Russia beat Argentina
um yeah II Tina had some good rounds
before so they suddenly ya popped up and
bought two against Russia but lost them
with Sega kayaking um winning
convincingly on bought two and three
draws then Armenian beated Netherlands
who also had a great run after a very
bad start but the media one very
convincingly then there was also
Azerbaijan playing Ukraine where Ukraine
one so um with a win by palomar often
three drawers so I'm before the last
round it's um let me just look at the
standings before the last round China is
leading the event and if I understand
them tie break rules correctly em if
they win the last round against Ukraine
not difficult or easy if they win
against Ukraine they'll be Olympic
champion and there's also a media and
Russia in
contention but only if China fails
against Ukraine then amenia Russia might
still win it but I'm not one hundred
percent certain about the the tiebreaker
rules it's a very close call also
Ukraine um is behind one point and if
Ukraine would be China amenia would lose
and also Russia would lose against
German even then Ukraine also has got a
very slight chance to still do something
as mentioned for the German um yes watch
the CM yeah Germany got Russia in the
last round so it's not at all easy it
could have been much easier in terms of
the drawing and then even Germany would
have a very slight very slight chance
maybe to get a medal but in this case
it's it's it's very difficult of course
because for metal you would need to yeah
beat Russia first and maybe even then it
wouldn't be enough all right so round
10mm as mentioned a mini abita the
netherlands and this is also the game
that i'll be featuring will be on
onigiri the young dutch number one only
18 years old against world's number to
levon aronian from amenia and let's see
what happened we've got a sloth defense
and in case you wonder i switched off
the board sounds this clucks and clocks
and check sounds I think it's sometimes
a bit annoying if you miss these um yeah
let me know in the comments alright
we've got sloth defense and geary here
place this line with queen bee three
this line is rather similar to quincy to
which I often play um and it's it's
quite an interesting way also queen bee
three as mentioned simula it's a very
interesting way against the Slav if you
don't want to contest any long for
Theoretical lines
still want to try for some advantage
then those Queen moves are interesting
very often the variations transpose into
each other if black captures obviously
this could also happen with Queen c2 c4
and then you get this kind of position
well White has chances for a very slight
advantage it's not much but it can be
something to play for in the long run
after queen bee three other aronian
played e6 and this is also difference
between the two Queen moves after quincy
to e6 is some maybe yeah not as good
let's put it this way because in this
structure with these six the queen is
slightly misplaced on v3 it's not an
ideal square the Queen would prefer to
be on c2 because you're more flexible
from c2 and also the Queen on c2 might
have to to support before at some point
for instance we would see it them and in
the game actually auntie replace g3 we
should be 750 to both sides castle and
not be descend in this kind of position
for example white would very much prefer
to have the Queen on c2 so that you can
play b3 bishop p 2 nite c 3 rd two and
then e four so on let's just okay this
is nonsense right it's a six I just want
to show that the idea then white could
could play something like this and go
for a four with the bishop here nicely
if he had shattered in the game I got
the Queen on v3 and Quincy to just would
be a loss of tempo and here you cannot
be enchanted the bishop so this is also
why give you a plate Bishop f4 it's not
bad at all but wyd probably would be
more like to see a shadow young e five
is an interesting move by ronnian it's
some sort of
semi waiting move it has some points
that might um disturb whites Queen at
some later stage it gains a little bit
of space and get a little bit
provocative also because it it's simply
not developing anything but it doesn't
really am hurt them like in any way and
white now has some a big amount of moves
of course event for oopsie one which is
designed to in case of move like a four
that wife can safely put the Queen back
on D 1 and then has the rookie in place
um this is not for the role you played
of course he played the tricky move h6
which really am yeah at first surprised
me I wasn't wasn't really understanding
what this move is doing but it has some
ideas one idea is that done if white
would try to prepare you for now with
them let's say I move like not be d 2
which would be rather natural to play
something like this Queen here or here
and then still play you for um yeah
unlike actually can play g5 it looks a
bit weird but it's it's quite a good
idea what would go here let play snide
g40 will win the bishop pair and also I
mean maybe he won't even take it but he
would have the possibility to take it
you can also play f5 later and has a
very active version of the stone wall
where white has some weird with replaced
pieces we should be 392 not sure um this
is I think quite good for black and on a
move like we should be five um yeah but
I can't even play here and for example
this kind of line leads to an
interesting position for black you can
attack the spawn and he's got two
bishops okay the c8 bishop is not great
yet
but the fun thing about to Bishop says
it's a long term asset it's not a
short-term thing very often you need
some time to get them both boobs into
play but one if they're really get going
and get into play then it gets really
difficult yeah this is one idea this g5
move of the movie h6 obviously not in
any case black play g5 but then Adam can
be um can be a good idea also note that
this a five move has another idea if
white would play 93 now for example then
black would have the tricky move a fall
the idea being if white would take now I
can take on c4 and any recapture is met
with b5 and black ones peace Quincy 6
there's also wrote a form so here white
actually would need to retreat the Queen
to do this another way over here we
actually need to retreat the Queen and
then black and play v5 it has an
interesting position so I'm quite quite
nice I think unclear obviously it's not
an advantage for black but it's
perfectly alright this is another idea
of this a formal um gira played a for
himself and this is to be honest if I
don't like very much but it um yeah it
obviously am I cannot adjust that this a
4 by black as some as an annoying idea
but I wouldn't like so much to give away
the before square maybe it's not done
it's not really bad but it's not a move
that I would like to play okay I'm
Aronian play tonight before this has two
ideas he wants to get the nod to be six
probably attacking the c-4 porn and also
there's of course f5 now so like a mixes
in stone
ideas he played not f.2d to now trying
to get rid of the the night note that if
right would play here then I five with
the idea of g5 would really be a yeah a
good way for black to to get active play
okay you went here and now I'm Aronian
came up with the interesting move from
96 keeping pieces on the board and just
asking white okay what I doing with your
night only to an I don't be one and stop
like and play a five so it keeps this
option open yeah Hickory um yeah sort of
wanted to clarify the position he took
on d6 and played a fun opening up the
whole thing and this Intel's or some
risks of course because it opens a
position against the bishop there but
it's it's not bad at all but i think he
pretty quickly played some problematic
moves it takes only for night takes and
Bishop before this is all very
understandable and I think I'm his next
move it's not really good he played c5
now this is of course in cause an
ambitious move if white would have
enough time then he would play stuff
like this I can also go from from d to
placing a night on see form and not only
for then this was really nicely bind on
the on the dark squares the problem is
that it is a bit too slow and we see
what the role ian is doing now plays
Knight f6 which one attacks the the
default porn by the way I think instead
of c-5 he should have played the simple
move like rookie one just just stay put
in this position I like black anyway but
two bishops but then this is certainly
around equal all right c 59 f six
taking deform and now I played Queen to
see for ya an alternative here would
have been 936 pretty much suggests
itself but then like would simply
retreat and now item has a choice you
can take on da don c 8 at first you
think okay why why should you ever take
on c 8 this is a bad bishop but the
problem is it doesn't stay a bad bishop
for long let's say takes him rook takes
and now even though on rook t1 like and
play e5 a problem is the c5 move
undermines the c5 phone also so
something like this is simply good for
black because he would take c5 and if I
was also week this is a temple so so
black is very nice here in this position
the problem is simply night takes yet
white white actually needs to take on c
8 and now play here and this is still I
think okay with this oops no on c4 with
this kind of idea or probably or maybe
just Knight c3 and I'm not quite sure
Knight c3 a2 card could also be an idea
yeah but simply get rid of the two
bishops so that if the position opens up
it not gets to too ugly I'm think maybe
96 worth the way to go he played Quincy
for this this is really this really
leads now to a black advantage like took
he retook and now aronian plate King
edge aid was it's a good move very
ambitious move also as we will see in
the game he actually could have played a
5 immediately and black would have a
very good game the problem is if white
takes it Queenie seven at xe5 and the
text c5 of course this is covered but
what is why doing about the five
let's say what would play for to secure
the pawn and black ones tempo Queen back
and then just move like I'm not sure
which look maybe this one and now the
problem is what is why doing in this
position he cannot move his night here
because well it gives a pawn on it would
allow rook t2 and this is already
disaster so I think I already lost maybe
this is this kind of stuff would
probably win instantly so this is simply
a terrible position I think it's
completely unplayable like as winning
already on at least a very clear
advantage so after after a five which
would have been really strong what must
play d fiber thing and then we would
have some position like this and I don't
want to get that in too much detail here
it's good for black and very similar to
what happened in the game and you see
that the game was also good for black so
I show the game and you see that it gets
pretty similar King edge eight is water
on your plate he now retreated the
bishop to g2 maybe it was better to to
play 93 m anticipating you five and out
d5 like has still a fine position with
something like this similar to the game
actually again but maybe this was still
more more and more resistance yeah
Bishop g2 and now dementia d5 very
similar to to be four bit the difference
is that after d5 what gear we played um
that's now the move f5 instead of taking
which was the move before without King
AJ but now of course f5 is possible and
it's also very aggressive move intending
to push further response
and really getting some attack maybe
even on white skin um yeah white now
took on c6 the problem is if he play
something like d6 which looks attractive
at first black simply plays something
along these lines Queen to f6 Bishop to
e6 Andy form and this pawn simply am
it's not going anywhere it won't promote
and black and always always play also be
62 to undermine the porn at later stage
so black just has a great position with
two bishops and white has nothing so
this is also I think why it took on c6
try to get some material at least and he
fought by wrong and this was the whole
concept killing the bishop on g2 and
sacrificing a pawn of course in the
process this is what happened and here
give you played c6 I think you I don't
have much choice if white would play a
normal developing move then something
like this rook c8 and later probably
maybe you Queenie seven you would get
the pawn back and then it's simply to
bishops for nothing also white has a
compromises queenside pawn structure so
black as as much better this is why he
pushed on on what c6 trying to get some
force in play going to get out of this
mess if why doesn't do something yeah
concrete it's simply am that he would
loose against the two bishops end and
this attacking ideas so c6 is perfectly
right trip to a six and queen bee three
now here he had an alternative actually
this is the movie seven which is yeah a
little bit of a computer move of course
I'm c7 let's move a human would think of
also pushing the bonus I'm very natural
the problem is after Queen e7 here Queen
c6 then black has the most III
and this is of course very dangerous for
white as some whites King isn't so well
protected in fact the only thing which
is some still playable is something on
something like this and if you come to
this point in your calculation you
frozen most likely it would assess that
as being too dangerous for white in fact
it probably is but then it's difficult
just the sample line here takes on c3
it's not necessarily the best when I'm
showing I just align that I looked at
before and obviously this gets dangerous
if white would take the exchange now
then black of course has a strong attack
is threatening we should be seven with
with checkmate already so you would
think about Queen f3 here um but them
there also there's also this idea which
also is made it's completely am it's
completely difficult to assess this
position Queenie a free maybe rook c8
and in the long run this this kind of
move will will cost you because probably
yeah it's very dangerous I think he
probably thought about c7 but them maybe
it simply seemed too dangerous he played
queen bee three then and now just rook
c8 black has all the time in the world
he just wants to get this pawn back and
then play on with his bishops yeah what
should why do now he decides to return
the pawn in order for some temper
temporary temporary activity it's
difficult to to keep it anyway well 93
was played
and aronian just took the pawn and now
95 this was viewers idea trying to trade
some some pieces but black and simply
retreat the bishop and set sides on on a
new point of the tag on f2 that we
should f1 to exchange some more and now
aronian really tried to force the matter
here he went with f4 very aggressive
move um and I think it's clear that dumb
black was somewhat better and the
late-stage share of the game for the
last let's say 10 moves but I think
here's the last chance for y2 to put up
a real fight he now I think needed to
really sacrifice the exchange here on c5
rook takes and night eggs and white them
threatens this move winning back the
exchange so black would probably play
something like this and in this position
I think like still has some chances of
course but I think what has a good night
on f4 some counterplay ideas it looks
like he can he can try to fight in this
position what he played though here I
think he loses Rob it simply losses I'm
it played night x f4 and now I'm he is
maybe a position where could stop the
video from moment and try to look for
for a good move for black Aronian now
played Bishop takes f 2 and this is a
very strong move the problem is if white
would take it then there's rook takes
that form
and Queen d2 and white gets completely
wiped out let's say King here and you
can simply try it down here because this
pin with the epod to move as just deadly
white will lose all its pieces here
maybe it's even a major force made in
the long run but simply the epod push
whence wins apiece wyd only has got 11
check here and now it's it's over it
cannot even protect f1 now so on white
couldn't take him and needed to play
King edge one now just look b6 attacking
the Queen to add web to see tune yeah I
think it's some very problematic anyway
and probably losing also Queen d5 was
also an idea it's possible that this was
a bit tougher but um like still has all
the chances with you should be seven for
example checking the Queen and getting
on this critical long diagonal so y term
would most likely take it and yeah then
you simply have this idea b2 is singing
there even alternatives earlier yeah
Queen D fibers maybe not they're not
much better he won Queen c2 and now just
III of course this pawn in itself as a
very dangerous attacking unit and still
black has ideas of sucking the exchange
we should be seven it's um it's very
difficult he played them Bishop g2 we
are covering the long diagonal I now
black gum has multiple ideas Queen g5
also would have been would have been
strong also need two men
of course if white would give the check
here like and simply take because of
this and now if why would retake it's
just made in two moves and okay white
cannot take on f1 then rip it the upon
will get very very ugly and Ed's also
simply again threatening mate so I'm it
was played Bishop g2 Queenie eight now
covering the g six square Queen g5 also
was fine Quincy five and now it just put
up this configuration of the roofs who
protect protect each other and yeah what
should why do it's it's really a mess
b-2s hanging the e pawn I'm yeah
threatens to advance at the moment
there's still this this kind of pin but
it's it's certainly a problematic IDM
plate them looxcie to covering the e2
square but now just g5 this breaks the
night the lights control yet over e 2
and d three so I'm a very strong move 95
was played in case of an IT too there's
this simple move and it wins some
material
yeah this is my 95 was played and it was
okay it looks looks nice but then
there's a simple movie too now
threatening promotion and down okay
white took 12 con a five and now black
them played the simple movie one Queen
it's um it's it's winning no no question
in fact this one rope be to d6 it's
probably even stronger preparing this
move but also i'm having the IDM to get
to the first rank here with checkmate
but okay aronian just promoted which is
of course enough to win the game white
takes like takes and at the end of this
like it's just an official app this you
want bishop and in addition there are
some the problem that these pawns are
also really am weekend it's a bad
structure so white cannot really use the
porn so immediately if white for example
would have the porn before already and
be able to push be five or so then it's
a completely different story but those
pawns are simply worthless really at the
moment and we see that aronian that's a
good job he needs to activate the King
first this is done yeah weiter gave the
way the g3 point to push before it
really doesn't matter it's a winning
position yeah you've got got the Jeep on
which is your winner porn is six ok need
to drop back of course to cover a seven
and now this pawn is
he lost watch played this move but after
yeah I think he resigned at the same
time according to my game file here of
course it's simply Bishop takes takes
and here intending to play this on g
three and then like simply wins this
porn and wins with the extra corn and
peace um by promoting the porn yeah and
a nice um display of the bishop pair
here by my Levon Aronian which was
allowed after girasole of Hamlet this
opening of the center not not really
young towards advantage yeah I think I'm
on an enjoyable game to watch i hope you
liked it this was as mentioned the
coverage of round 10 so there's only one
round left on sunday this will also be
an earlier round started down at i don't
know i think four hours earlier than
usual so i'll do a wrap-up video of the
last round also announcing wonder thing
at the end i'll do a wrap-up video on on
sunday sunday afternoon yeah i hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching